[Music]  Katy Perry and Orlando Bloom appear to  be going strong the lovebirds were  spotted out in London together for a  night on the town  here's Katy in Orlando leaving  Annabelle's club on Thursday popstar  looking cozy in a bright pink lingerie  slip paired with comfy seekers while  bloom kept things casual in a  button-down shirt jeans and baseball cap  a source tells ET the couple has been  enjoying quality time together across  the pond while the 41 year old actor  performs killer Joe on Broadway our  source says Katy and Orlando are more  private about their romance these days  you just have to know where to draw the  lines set boundaries adding quote  Orlando and Katy were very public the  first time around and being more low-key  about their relationships  everyone's a teacher in a relationship  that's how I see it now and we've taught  each other